se puede considerar como una provocación
que Rusia haga estos juegos militares en
América Latina justo en medio de las
tensiones con occidente por la guerra en
Ucrania o está lejos de ser esto Buenas
noches claro
Sí evidentemente y lo ha dicho
públicamente de Putin él quiere cambiar
el mundo y hacerlo multipolar Pero
además de eso ahí hay otras
maniobras ocultas y ya una la desveló
hoy que es la la venta masiva de armas
Eso es parte de de las intenciones que
tienen que venir pero evidentemente que
él quiere penetrar el continente
iberoamericano
y hacer de aliados de todos estos países
Especialmente los países donde está
gobernando la izquierda la extrema
izquierda
y profundicemos en esto que usted está
hablando porque los juegos militares
coinciden con el foro arnia 2022 en el
que el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
ofreció armamento a sus aliados que
tanto puede Entonces fortalecerse de esa
relación militar con países como
Venezuela Nicaragua y Cuba y si podría
volver un escenario similar al de la
crisis de los misiles de la Guerra Fría
bueno no creo que que se llega a la
crisis de la de la Guerra Fría pero sí
evidentemente que hay algo comercial por
parte de Rusia y a Rusia le ha vendido a
Venezuela más de 10.000 millones de
dólares en El karma Ahora hay una hay
una hay un mercadeo muy equivocado hoy
en día porque con tantos golpes que le
están dando las fuerzas armadas rusas en
Ucrania y con y el armamento que está
resultando deficiente tácticamente con
respecto al armamento de occidente
evidentemente que se impondrá más la
ideología para las compras esas armas
que la eficiencia del sistema de los
sistemas de armas míticos
Estados Unidos se ha mostrado más
cercano a Venezuela y a Colombia donde
habrá el primer gobierno de izquierda
hay una nueva disputa de influencia
entre Estados Unidos y Rusia
Sí sí
desde que cayó el muro Berlín desde que
se acabó la guerra fría por supuesto
Rusia se ha se ha venido mermando tanto
como sistemas de armas como de geografía
porque muchos países aliados se les han
pasado a la otan pero evidentemente que
es tratar de de pisar el patio de los
aliados tradicionales de Estados Unidos
en el continente americano